herzlich willkommen ja ich weiß ja nicht
wie es ihnen geht aber ich selbst bin
sehr gespannt auf die heutige
sternstunde
denn mein gesamtes weltbild würde über
den haufen geworfen wenn ein gast
wirklich recht hätte walter von lucadou
glaubt nämlich anspruch an telepathie
und dann war träume er ist aber nicht
irgendein dahergelaufener esoterischer
spinnen sondern promovierter physiker
und psychologe und ein weltweit
führender experte wenn es um die
erklärung übersinnliche phänomene geht
herzlich willkommen herr von jagow
herzlich willkommen wir wollen heute
über sogenannte paranormale phänomene
sprechen ich möchte mit dem spuk wir
gehen also mit der tatsache dass
manchmal uhren einfach so stillstehen
oder gegenstände zu boden fallen sich
bewegen oder der fernseher einschaltet
oder ausschaltet ja was er jetzt gerade
8 wenn es solche dinge passieren ja dann
kann man sie anrufen sie haben nämlich
seit 30 jahren eine in der
beratungsstelle in freiburg im breisgau
wo sie über ca 3000 ungefähr anrufe
kriegen
wie reagieren sie da was sagen sie den
leuten nicht helfen sie wenn so was also
ist so was ich sagen muss sie haben
vorhin gesagt dass ich an spuckt glauben
wissenschaftler hat prinzipiell nichts
zu glauben sondern dinge zu überprüfen
aber ich glaube dass die leute mir
keinen bären aufbinden
und zwar deswegen weil so viele menschen
sind die solche sachen berichten die
können nicht alle vorhaben meine bücher
gelesen haben und mir dann die
geschichten erzählen die ich erwarte
aber es zeigt sich doch dass diese
geschichten die sie erzählen gewisse
strukturen aufweisen und das heißt das
dass ein element der realität ist nur
wissen wir nicht genau welches und das
erste was ich tue
wir hören einfach mal ganz gründlich zu
und wir intervenieren ganz wenig weil
wir ja den originalbericht haben wollen
wir wollen wissen was die leute wirklich
erlebt haben das wird im zeit des
internets immer schwieriger
beide geschichten hören sie da also das
sind geschichten des häufigstes sind
sogenannte war träume das jemanden ganz
lebhaften traum hat und hinter
feststellt dass dieser traum tatsächlich
eintrifft das sind
für die leute wirklich richtig
problematisch sein wenn jemand zb von
einem unfall träumt man muss dazu sagen
wenn er den traum vorher erzählt hat
dass man auch sicher ist dass wirklich
geträumt hat und das ist keine
erinnerungs täuschung sind enttäuschung
heißt man klar später man hätte das
genau richtig und wenn sicher ist dass
das ereignis auch so stattgefunden hat
und erst nicht selbst ausgelöst hat also
wenn jemand sagt ich hab heut nacht
anrufe von einem unfall geträumten
steigt dann selber ins auto dann hat das
ja möglicherweise selbst herbeigeführt
also da muss man ein bisschen drauf
achten arbeit das ist so häufig dass man
sagen kann das eigentlich schon fast
normal
man hat bevölkerungsumfragen gemacht als
auch repräsentative und hat festgestellt
dass ungefähr zwei drittel der menschen
wenn man sie fragt ob sie schon mal so
was erlebt haben und man gibt ein
beispiel sagen ja hab ich auch schon mal
erlebt aber nicht alles sagen dass über
natürlich nicht alles sagen manche sagen
müssen zufall manche sagen ja das war
jetzt hellsehen oder präpositionen
manche sagen ach ich habe mir das
vielleicht doch nur eingebildet also die
reaktionen darauf sind ganz untersagen
darüber werden wir heute glaube ich auch
viel diskutieren wie man solche
phänomene
solche erlebnisse die es einfach gibt
menschen erleben solche sachen wie man
die interpretiert und genau darum geht
es und jetzt beim spuk noch mal bei
diesen dingen wo wegen wie gegenstände
zu quotenfrauen und zur reiter haben
sich mal selbst sowie natürlich also ich
bin tatsächlich schon in wohnungen
gestanden da sah es aus als hätte eine
bombe eingeschlagen und die leute sagen
wir haben das nicht gemacht und da
können sie sich vorstellen dass die
leute ein problem haben aber die leute
waren zu hause aus dass dies ja jetzt
muss man folgendes dazu sagen wir kommen
eigentlich zu solchen fällen erst hin
wenn alle möglichkeiten die man erwartet
wie technische störungen schabernack von
nachbarn ungezogene nordviertel girls
heißt es also ungezogene kinder die
sowas anrichten wenn es schon alles
ausgeschlossen ist da war schon die
polizei da hat da waren schon technische
hilfskräfte da da
haben die leute schon alles gründlich
untersucht und erst dann kommen sie auf
die idee das könnte ja was naja
paranormales sein und dann rufen sie uns
an wir schauen uns das dann vor ort an
aber meistens machen wird es nicht wir
hören uns am telefon an
warum weil dieses buch fälle immer
ziemlich ähnlich aussehen das kann man
sagen das ist fast so was wie ein
klischee das muss da ein muster was
immer wieder auftritte mich wieso also
meistens sind am anfang geräusche wir
nennen die auch mimikry geräusche hört
sich an als ob jemand was bestimmtes tut
also zum beispiel nach baar amrum läuft
dann geht man hin hoppla wer ist denn da
und dann ist niemand da oder dass man
das geräusch vom computer einschalten
hört und denkt wir schalteten da den
computer ein geht darüber ist niemand da
oder das klappt ja damals schon aus dem
handy zum beispiel an denn sie hat
geklingelt aber ja es gibt also es ist
ein geräusche die ganz normale
alltägliche geräusche sind findet die
ursache nicht und natürlich glauben die
leute erstmals die haben sich getäuscht
aber es wird dann so massiv dass die
leute merken das stimmt was nicht
und dann das nächste sind eben
bewegungen von gegenstände das plötzlich
also zum beispiel glas auf boden fällt
oder gegenstände durch die luft fliegen
und dann lernen die leute schon da
stimmt was nicht oder hat er oder auch
was auch vorkommt dass zum beispiel
flüssigkeiten wasser verschüttet wird
also wirklich einräumen gestand da
standen die wasserlachen aber sie kommen
ja erst wenn die wasserlachen auf dem
boden ist oder haben sie selbst ja das
sage ich gleich was dazu also aber das
ist das was die leute berichten und dann
holen die natürlichen techniker und
sagen bei uns ist die wasserleitungen
leitung nicht dicht oder ein anderes
phänomen was auf auch auftritt was sehr
irritierend ist dass brände ausbrechen
also es ist irgendwo anfängt zu brennen
und dann kommt natürlich die polizei und
dann geht es um brandstiftungen und so
und erst wenn festgestellt ist das haben
die leute nicht selber gemacht und auch
niemand anders
brandsachverständige und sagen wir haben
keine ahnung was zu sein kann und dann
kommen wir ins spiel und dann gibt es
natürlich vermutung dessen technische
störungen und so weiter und dann guckt
man mal nach aber was wir relativ
schnell raus finden ist
dass es eben keine technischen störung
sind dass es keine irrtümer keine
täuschung sind sondern dass das was mit
den betreffenden leuten zu tun hat also
wenn sie so wollen dass es einen
psychologischen zusammenhang gibt und
das ist das wichtigste erst dann
sprechen wir eigentlich funkspruch
eigentlich benutze ich dieses wort gar
nicht gern weil das ist halt so
folkloristisch wir sprechen hier er von
einem von einer and body went störung
oder einem body went phänomen dass das
werden wir jetzt leider erläutern sie
haben mir aber gesagt das hat mit den
menschen ja tun und das wollten wir auch
wissen welche menschen denn diese
wesentlichen drehte haben oder welche
menschen das besonders interessiert ein
bisschen auf die straße gegangen und
haben eine umfrage genommen und waren
erstaunt wie viele menschen schon so
diese dinge erlebt haben nach ein
früherer im seeland wohnt und ich bin zu
gummi jetzige martina wohnt und türkisch
oder andere notimex sie und dass ich mir
bestätigt worden vor ebenso dummen
feriengästen oberliga hamburg zu mir
gesagt du wir sind nicht allein da muss
natürlich seid ja ich weiß es und wo mir
versuches verkaufen wollen haben es
nicht verkauft und den haben wir uns
häufig macht und und mensch stellt für
das haus das da hat denn der geist mit
knoten also mehr paris gestorben
damals war ich 18 einhalb jahre ich habe
nicht an gott geglaubt damals und da
habe ich erst mal mein leben vater unser
gebetet die bin im bett gelegen habe
gelesen mein kätzchen der pc lag um ein
holz herumfahren motor show und weg war
und ich habe das gefühl gehabt dass
meine für sitzt irgendwer dann habe ich
mir gedacht das bildest du dir ein ja
aber es war wirklich so und ich habe
gänsehaut gehabt am ganzen körper und
ich wollte mein papa am nächsten tag
besuchen wir mit der freundin der karen
das war in kärnten und ja genau wie
vaterunser gebetet weil ich so angst
gehabt habe und in der noch das meer
papa von ein lkw-fahrer zusammengefahren
wollen ja und deshalb weiß ich dass er
da war ich glaube 20 meter mit dass man
dankt und manche sind mehr vernetzt und
es gibt es gibt die energie
ich weiß nicht wie man der besagt dass
teleport ihr kollektiv die energie und
die hier macht sich bemerkbar
und ich hoffe die maxime richtwerte
bemerkt kann man sagen welche menschen
denn besonders empfänglich sind für
solche phänomene und in welchen
lebensphasen ja also wir haben
festgestellt weil wir also erstaunlich
viele solcher spur quelle haben also ich
habe vorhin gesagt es hauptsächlich so
war träume aber das nächst häufiges sind
eigentlich schon diesen spuk fälle wobei
natürlich nicht alles so dramatisch sind
manchmal gibt es auch so mundt mini spuk
fälle wo dann nur einmal was passiert
aber es ist eben überhaupt nicht selten
und da haben wir natürlich schon
geschaut welche menschen erleben so was
und da stellt sich ihm heraus das ist
eigentlich so fünf faktoren gibt die
müssen erfüllt sein damit es spukt aber
das reicht natürlich nicht aus also und
die zähle ich jetzt einfach mal auf
erstens haben diese menschen die so was
erleben können die sind also nicht
psychisch krank das muss man mal ganz
wichtig vor ausstellen sind ganz normale
menschen ganz im gegenteil sind
eigentlich eher gesünder als andere aber
sie haben eine bestimmte eigenschaft die
nennen wir die sozia zions bereitschaft
oder die sozietät das heißt das sind
menschen die haben die fähigkeit auch
mal so ganz anders zu sein das sind
häufig kreative leute künstler oder so
der künstlerische begabung sein
die haben so einem zweiten inneren
dialogpartner also das nennt man die
sozietät in der psychologie aber darf
ich fragen aber sie bekommen nach anrufe
von menschen muss sich vermuten da der
hat vielleicht eine psychische störung
dagegengehalten ja das kommt auch vor
aber dass das nicht diese klassischen
spezielle da ist gerade nicht so die
zweite eigenschaft ist dass sie dass die
personen den
passiert wir haben eine fähigkeit die
auch sehr verbreitet ist die nennen der
externalisierung externalisierung heißt
dass ich dinge mir vom hals halten
also ich will ein simples beispiel
nehmen wenn sie hier in der schweiz und
man ist ja nicht machen aber wenn man
geblitzt wird weil man zu schnell
gefahren ist da gibt es zwei typische
reaktionen die einen sagen auch je ein
hat mich aufgepasst und zahlen halt und
beschimpfen durchdrücken sage ja das war
wieder eine falle ich bin ganz normal
gefahren und das war hier nur so
eingerichtet dass ich jetzt hier zahlen
nicht ich bin das problem sind ja genau
und es nimmt man externalisierung also
sich vom hals halten
dies sind zwei ganz wichtige
eigenschaften die die spuck focus
personen zu nennen wird die auszeichnen
dann kommt noch was dazu nämlich dass
die betreffenden ein sagt man mal ein
problem haben was sie aber selber nicht
sehen also jeder mannschaft probleme
aber beim spuk ist immer so dass es ein
problem ist was die leute nicht im
visier haben was sie von denen sie nicht
wissen dass wir das problem haben auch
sie verdrängen
ja sie sind zum teil verdrängte probleme
aber auch zum teil probleme diese gar
nicht sehen diese einfach nicht sehen
manchmal sagt der spuk es können ganz
alltägliche dinge sah ich werde man nach
ein beispiel stellen wo man es sieht
also ganz alltäglichen lebens probleme
also nicht mord und totschlag wie in
gruselfilm sondern ganz normale
alltägliche probleme die die leute aber
nicht sehen das sind die drei
psychologischen faktoren dann muss es
natürlich sozusagen beobachter geben
also es muss leute geben die diesen
spruch beobachten können die
das sehen könnten sonst das wie so eine
botschaft die jemand hören muss und dann
schließlich das finde ich das
erstaunliche die leute bei den spukt
haben eine ganz erstaunliche robustheit
das heißt es sind sowohl psychisch als
auch körperlich sehr gesund die werden
einfach nicht krank man kann fast sagen
der spuk ist sozusagen das ein ventil
wo andere leute psychosomatisch
reagieren also krank werden rückenleiden
oder asthma oder sonstwas weil es in
psychischer probleme haben was sie nicht
sehen was ihn verdrängt haben
bei personen die lagerndes nach außen
die halten sich das vom hals und
deswegen sage ich von leuten die uns
anrufen seien bei mir spukt sich freuen
sie sich sind die leute total überrascht
und sein glaube ich mich da freuen dass
sie bleiben gesund sie werden nicht
krank natürlich muss man das problem
abstellen was dahinter steckt aber das
ist so ein mechanismus der natur um
psychosomatische erkrankungen zu
vermeiden und deswegen ist es vollkommen
falsch anzunehmen dass psychisch dass
die leute psychisch krank sind oder
sowas aber sie gerade nicht der fall
jetzt habe ich ganz viele dinge nicht
verstanden ja das würde ja heißen dass
ein problem mit dem ich mich nicht
auseinander setzt sich das schlägt mir
jetzt nicht auf den morgen gehen sondern
auf die richtigen auf die uhr im
wohnzimmer hängt ihnen die dann
irgendwie spinnt oder zu boden fällt das
ist die härte und man kann es so zu
sagen an dem was passiert wenn man es
geschickt anstellt kann man herausfinden
wo das problem steckt das ist wie so ein
ich sage immer wie ein in die realität
hinüber getreten hat raum und den kann
ich so analysieren wie ein psychologe
ein traum analysiert um herauszufinden
wo jemand ein verdrängtes problem hat
ich bin jetzt ein beispiel das manchmal
sieht das war ein ziemlich dramatischer
fall wo also immer brennende auftauchten
und
zunächst dachte man störungen technische
störungen zunächst ans kabel die
brannten dann später kalender alles
mögliche fanden fing an zu brennen
aber natürlich immer nur wenn eine
bestimmte person da war aber das wussten
die leute nicht das war sogar einer
firma und die leute haben mich dann
geholt werden sehen war auch schon da
und ich habe dann den chef gefragt wie
gesagt bei einer firma und sagen sie mal
wann hat es zuerst einmal gebrannt und
das sagte der zu mir ja also ich habe
mein büro angestellten gesagt er musste
auf eine geschäftsreise gehen
er ruft mich nur an wenn es brennt und
er fuhr an seinem büro vorbei und sah
wie der qualm aus einem fenster kam also
das heißt dann wie gesagt na ja sie
haben sozusagen die idee geliefert und
dann stellte sich als wahr heraus mal
ganz kurz die focus person war eine
junge frau die dort volontierte und die
hatte wohl schwierige
familienverhältnisse und hatte diesen
sehr netten firmenchef sozusagen als
papa ist ersatzpapa adoptiert und das
war eigentlich sehr nett zuvor auch ein
wirklich sehr netter mann und dann
passierte freund ist das eben weil da
immer brände ausbrachen war da
vernünftiges arbeiten nicht mehr möglich
und dann kam eben die ehefrau von dem
firmenchef um aufzuräumen um zu helfen
keiner wusste keiner sah diese
psychologische zusammenhänge und dann
fing plötzlich die jalousien an zu
brennen die eigentlich aus dem material
sind was gar nicht brennen kann und dann
haben wir halt so erzählt und dann hab
ich gesagt wissen sie eigentlich was
jalousie heißt und es mussten die nicht
aber er wird jalousie das kommt aus dem
französischen yahoo heißt eifersüchtig
und als ich das gesagt haben fiel die
endgültige sozusagen der kiewer wunder
weil sie sofort kapiert haben der spuk
ersetzt symbolisch das problem
und wenn man da ein bisschen übung hat
dann kann man genau sehen warum es bucht
und wenn man dann die ursache abstellt
und dafür sorgt dass die dahinter
liegenden probleme bereinigt sind dann
hört sofort auf während bei
psychosomatischen reaktionen da gehört
es eben nicht sofort auf weil der körper
die stöße angelernt
wahnsinnige geschichte also wenn das
wenig verstehen das würde ja heißen die
ist eifersüchtig beliebt aber weiß nicht
was da ist nicht da sie möchte jetzt
irgendwie kommunizieren und loslassen
also sie fasst der wende haben der weg
ging dann fing es an zu brennen
er musste wieder kommen und das war
sozusagen der mechanismus hat er selber
gar nicht gewusst und das läuft
unbewusst ab das konnte mal da waren
dass man sein hat ich habe mit dem
geräte der hat gesagt da steht vor einem
rätsel
also da war die polizei alles können sie
zu vorstellen da war ich meinte van
schaden der in die tausende von euro
gehen wenn sie erzählen dass du mit
deiner selbstverständlichkeit ich meine
sie machen dass er die zentrale sich 40
jahren kennen sie sich noch zurück
erinnern aussieht noch gestammt haben
und ihr ganzes weltbild irgendwie ins
wanken gerät aus geschichten in mein
weltbild gering eigentlich nicht ins
wanken weil mein eigentlicher ansatz wir
haben wir hier den philosophen
diskussionskreis war die philosophie und
zwar habe ich noch als schüler das also
liegt jetzt über 50 jahre zurück 2 64
das buch von hans triesch gelesen para
psychologie die wissenschaftler kunden
erscheinungen und hans driesch war ja
biologe und philosoph in leipzig und der
hat es sich mit der frage beschäftigt ob
denn die lebensvorgänge physikalische
erklärt werden können damals gab es eine
riesen diskussion darüber und es gab
ganze reihe von philosophen die gesagt
haben
das geht nicht die physik die bezieht
sich auf die unbelebte natur und die
biologie schon kann man nicht
vollständig auf die physik reduzieren
und da hat man dann so ein ansatz
gemacht der hans driesch hat es endlich
ii genannt also sowas wie lebenskraft
oderberg song hat es genau und er das
hatte ich gelesen und der hat nun
solches buch fälle als beispiele dafür
gebracht dass dieser in langwied all
dieser in delhi sozusagen hier direkt
wirkt jetzt muss man dazu sagen wir
haben mittlerweile herausgefunden in der
biologie hat mal rausgefunden dass es
diese endlich ihn nicht gibt
aber wir haben herausgefunden was das
eigentlich ist was dahinter steckt und
das finde ich eigentlich sehr spannend
also er eigentlich war es ein
philosophischer ansatz nämlich die frage
sind das eingebildete sachen oder ist da
wirklich steckt möglichen prozess
dahinter denen wir verstehen können also
dass nun endlich ein insider zum
beispiel ein schließen dass es bloße
illusion halluzination einbildung sind
wenn man das einfach mal mit deinem
video kamera filmen würde das einfach an
vergessen oder einstein das haus als
jetzt denn das oder ja da muss man zwei
dinge sagen also das erste wollte ich ja
vorhin schon noch anfügen ist natürlich
erleben psychisch kranke auch reale
sachen aber man kann wirklich sehr gut
unterscheiden zwischen einer
psychotischen erfahrung und einem realen
spuk hat jemand der sie zufrieden ja der
analyse hat auch dinge die er nicht
versteht und die ihm angst machen aber
andere leute sind da nix die
unterscheiden sind dann die
unterscheiden sich sozusagen in ihrer
machart und in ihrer ich ihre gestalt
typischerweise sind erkrankungen immer
in einer gewissen weise einschränkung
also jemand der einer psychischen
erkrankung leidet er hat einschränkung
der kann ich so gut denken der fühlt
sich eingeschränkt er hat angst während
das haben wir vorher gesehen die leute
die sowas erleben sind ganz normale
menschen und die haben zeigen keinerlei
psychotische eigenschaften die haben
keine denkstörungen nichts dergleichen
es wird ihnen häufig unterstellt weil
man ihnen nicht glaubt aber dass die
erleben sind reale dinge die sie sehen
können und die andere auch sehen aber
und jetzt kommt die entscheidende frage
warum gibt es keine perfekten
dokumentationen vom spiel und das
wünscht man sich ja immer ein
akademischer lehrer hans bender der ist
man mit videokamera oder filmkamera rom
gereist und wollte immer den spuk
einfangen und wir wissen heute dass das
extrem schwierig ist nicht nur deswegen
weil die dinge immer spontan auftreten
und unerwartet sondern weil sie die
eigenschaft haben immer da aufzutreten
wo ich gerade nicht mit befasst bin wo
ich weil
es ist ein art psychisches versteckspiel
also wenn ich jetzt wüsste als nächstes
fliegt diese dieses glas hier los dann
könnte ich mich hinsetzen die kamera
draufhalten dann würde ich es irgendwie
es wegfliegt aber die umgebung weiß
jetzt dass ich das für richtig so ist es
gab das ist ja einfach wirklich also ein
skeptiker würde sorger nüchtern der
skeptiker würde sagen es ist eine
perfekte schutzstaffel orientierung
munition stadt das ist nicht voraus
offizier war die jacke so was machen sie
mit ja das kriege ich auch vorgehalten
also wir sind ja hier in der schweiz
also einige skeptiker haben gesagt der
luca der macht sich einfach der
behauptet die alpen bestehen eigentlich
aus vortrefflicher schweizer milch
schokolade aber wenn man danach gräbt
verwandelt sich in stein
okay das sage ich aber nicht es ist
nämlich keine immunisierung streit immer
könnte es so auffassen
aber das was passiert hat bestimmte
eigenschaften die zeigen dass es
wirklich eine eigenschaft des systems
ist dass das sozusagen zu dem system
dazu gehört und es ist keineswegs so
dass man nicht nachweisen kann dass da
was passiert man kann es nur nicht so
einfach fotografieren
das heißt der spuk ist lucy iv so sein
wird das lose oder flüchtig aber wir
können diese flüchtigkeit trotzdem im
griff kriegen und zwar experimentell
also jetzt müssen sie erzählen sie haben
nämlich wirklich eine theorie wie das
ausgeht wir sozusagen ein in meinen
verstand dann irgendwie diese uhr zum
zum runterfahren oder zum stillstehen
bringt es gibt nämlich so was wie eine
verschwörung es gibt deshalb mit
quantenmechanik mit quantenphysik danach
jetzt müssen sie ja also zunächst mal
hat man immer geglaubt und es ist
eigentlich heute in den das haben wir
auch da in dem interview gehört die
leute denken dass sind energien und
kräfte die wir noch nicht kennen
nach diesen energien und kräften hat man
100 jahre lang gesucht und hat sie nicht
gefunden und trotzdem hat man immer
wieder diese effekte kriegt man hat ja
experimente angestellt so genannte
psycho chinesen experimente im
einfachsten fall wo jemand versucht den
würfel so zu beeinflussen dass das
rauskommt was er will
da hat man tausende von experimenten
gemacht
dann später hat man natürlich bessere
versuch also besser zufalls prozesse
verwendet nicht der würfel ist einfach
zu unzuverlässig aber es gab immer
wieder erfolgreiche experimente also
wenn behauptet wird es hätte keine
erfolgreiche experimente geben dann
stimmt es einfach nicht aber der punkt
war der diese experimente zeigen einen
merkwürdigen charakter nämlich dass es
sich nicht leicht ich wiederholen lassen
wenn man das gleiche experiment noch
einmal macht ganz genau das gleiche mit
der gleichen personen der gleichen
person oder mit anderen personen und man
macht alles identisch gleich dann kriegt
man zwar wieder ein effekt effekt aber
der ist schwächer und es heißt man hat
das nennen wir die kleinen effekt
absenkung effekt und dieser absenkung
effekt der wurde bisher immer so
psychologisch erklärt so mit den leuten
wird es langweilig und oder die die
versuch situation ist nicht optimal und
so wir sehen dahinter gekommen dass
diese absenkung effekt ein szenischer
eigenschaft von psycho chinesen oder
spuk ist das heißt dahinter steckt keine
kraft dahinter steckt keine energie ist
und was anderes was wir jetzt als
verschränkung bezeichnen und es muss man
erläutern den begriff der verschränkung
den gibt es noch nicht so lange gibt es
seit ungefähr 100 jahren in der physik
und es hat tatsächlich 100 jahre
gedauert bis man verstanden hat was
dahintersteckt verschränkung ist nämlich
keine energieübertragung sind reine
keine kein kraft sein kann signal
sondern verschränkung heißt auf gut
deutsch ein muster zusammenhang der
selber eine ursache hat aber eben keine
kausale ursache verschränkung ist ein
nicht kausaler prozess genau also es
gibt ja diese berühmten experimente der
quantenphysik wo man zwei
elementarteilchen in zwei photonen zum
beispiel oder auch elektron und die
beiden sind verschränkt das heißt wenn
die sich die das eine teilchen so dreht
dann muss ich das andere in die andere
richtung drehen so weit müssen und jetzt
aber wenn man jetzt dieses hier da die
richtung ändert dann dreht sich eben
auch hier die richtung und zwar egal wie
nahe die beiden
oder das ist ja ganz genau stimmt es
nicht das ist wirklich eine subtile
angelegenheit und es ist hochaktuell
also man hat diese experimente
durchgeführt das nennt man das welsche
theorie
das waren physiker der in genf
gearbeitet hat der hat in den 60er
jahren zum ersten mal die sache
formuliert und der hat gesagt es ist
eigentlich so wenn ich jetzt so zwei
teilchen haben und ich schickte
auseinander
dann gilt für die erhaltungssatzung so
seine tritt sich links andere rechts rum
so weit so gut so wenn ich jetzt dass
eine messe und feststelle dass sich das
links dreht dann kann ich mit sicherheit
voraussagen dass andere sich rechts
herum drehen so weit so gut
das gilt auch für klassische teilchen
aber jetzt kommt was dazu
was immer bei klassischen teilchen nicht
findet wenn ich mir nämlich jetzt
überlegt ich will jetzt nicht in dieser
richtung schauen sondern ich schaue
jetzt in der richtung
dann stelle ich fest dass mein späterer
entschluss in eine andere richtung zu
gucken sich bei dem anderen auch zeigt
das ist etwas was man überhaupt nicht
erwartet hat genau und java und auch war
diese dinge wirklich nicht kausal gibt
es keine immunisierung sein sollten
sondern irgendwie hat seine verschenken
die können nach sehr sehr sehr weit aus
natürlich deswegen hat der arbeit
einsteigen ja auch von einer spukhaften
fernwirkung ganz genau gesprochen und
wollte ja nicht so wirklich da und
deswegen jahr einstellen
der lebte hatte noch so eine klassische
welt vorstellungen wo alles festgelegt
ist und deswegen hat er gesagt das kann
doch gar nicht sein das ist eine
teilchen irgendetwas über das andere
weiß wenn sie so weit auseinander sind
dass sie nicht mehr über ein signal sich
austauschen können
und da hat man dann experimente gemacht
und festgestellt dass es tatsächlich
trotzdem so ist nun muss man folgendes
dazu sagen das ist eine ganz trickreiche
situation es gibt es gab bis jetzt bis
vor kurzem noch eine offene frage
und zwar war das argument folgendes also
ich kann mir immer überlegen in welche
richtung ich in der einen seite messe
und dann richtet sich die andere seite
danach so einfach
gedrückt ja aber dann hat man gesagt
einige physiker haben gesagt ja gut
wodurch bestimme ich in welche richtung
ich drehe die natur weiß ja vielleicht
in welche richtung ich drehen will
und dann weiß die natur dass er auf der
anderen seite auch drehen muss in die
richtige richtung und dann ist es wieder
klassisch und deswegen hat man jetzt
gerade ein experiment es wurde jetzt gar
vor kurzem publiziert da hat man leute
gebeten zufallszahlen zu erzeugen
einfach zu raten und die zahlen die
wurden alle in das physikalische labor
genommen und die hat man jetzt bin
verwendet diese zufallszahlen um
sozusagen den detektor unterschiedliche
einzustellen und hat gesagt das ist
jetzt nicht determiniert weil das durch
irgendein physikalischen prozess wie zb
zufallsgenerator erzeugt wurde sondern
das ist der freie wille der leute die
irgendeine zahl nennen so und jetzt
kriegt man total interessantes
philosophisches problem denn es geht auf
die frage hinaus hat der menschen freien
willen
oder ist der freie wille der scheinbar
freie wähler auch nur determiniert durch
die gesamte welt jetzt haben wir unsere
sendung ja ich mir das einige zeit aber
die spielt jetzt eine entscheidende
rolle jetzt gibt's neurologen
neurowissenschaftler die sagen es gibt
gar keinen freien willen also das ist
libet versuche usw
die würden sagen das experiment ist
nicht überzeugend die physiker die das
gemacht haben aber gesagt nein dem
freien willen gibt sehr wohl und
deswegen nehme ich das als kriterium
jetzt muss ich noch mal zurück zum
stunden quasi erklären ich wissen warum
diese uhr jetzt zu boden fällt sie haben
was das mit der person zu tun ja die
land problem hat und dann sagen sie es
gibt irgendwie eine verschränkung
zwischen diesen beiden zuständen
zwischen psychiaters das betroffenen und
diesem ist dieser wohnung
und da ist das schon so also soweit ich
weiß gibt die physik davon aus dass
diese verschränkung nur im sehr sehr
kleinen bereich ist will auch immer
gesagt super und so maren jahr bereich
und das stimmt natürlich überhaupt nicht
also das ist jetzt ein interessanter
punkt bisher dass die meisten also die
meisten die gegen mich argumentieren da
habe ich schon viel trescher eingezogen
da für die sagen der lukaku behauptet
die qual
physik würde für die paranormalen
phänomenen erklärung liefern das
behaupte ich gar nicht das habe ich noch
nie behauptet ich sage es ist das ganz
anderes es ist so wir haben in der
quantenphysik gelernt dass es
verschränkung gibt und dann stellen wir
fest dass es auch andere systeme gibt
wie zum beispiel die psychologie da
gibt's auch verschränkung aber nicht aus
quantenphysikalischen gründen sondern
weil dahinter eine bestimmte struktur
steht und das wird erklärt durch eine
theorie die hat man römer hauptsächlich
entwickelt hat das und theoretischer
physiker aus freiburg und das nennt sich
verallgemeinerte quantentheorie das ist
keine quantentheorie sondern das ist
eine systemtheorie und die basiert auf
einer ganz simplen annahme die so
einfach ist dass man sich fragen muss
warum die leute nicht früher darauf
gekommen sind war fragt er sich einfach
also eine ganz simple frage wenn ich zum
beispiel irgendeine messung nach
irgendwas meister wie zum beispiel die
länge von diesem tisch
dann brauche ich ein metermaß dass
lediglich an und dann stelle ich fest
wie die länge des tisches ist dann kann
ich auch mal andere messungen machen ich
kann zum beispiel das gewicht bestimmen
indem ich das ding auf die waage stellen
ja so okay soweit alles klar
so jetzt gehe ich normalerweise ohne zu
hinterfragen davon aus dass das gleiche
herauskommt wenn ich erst die länge
messe und das gewicht oder wenn ich erst
das gewicht mehr so und dann die länger
denkbar dass das doch seit verständlich
in der physik hat man gelernt dass das
nicht der fall ist es gibt physikalische
größen bei denen das nicht der fall ist
die nennt man dann nicht vertauscht war
so in der psychologie haben wir das
jeden tag bin ich ihnen jetzt zb ein
stimmungs fragebogen gibt der ihre
momentane stimmung meist misst sozusagen
kommt raus so es geht ihm ganz gut
das ist in neugierig und vielleicht ein
bisschen aufgeregt aber es geht ja ok ja
wenn ich ihnen aber jetzt so ein
intelligenz fragebogen vorlege und auf
die uhr schauen nächste frage nächste
frage
dann sind sie hinterher schweißgebadet
jetzt überlegen sie sich macht es einen
unterschied ob ich ihnen herzlich
stimmen frage und dann den intelligenz
fragebogen oder umgekehrt macht einen
riesenunterschied so so weit so gut also
wir haben in der psychologie fast
ständig nicht vertauscht barop serben zu
nehmen wir das also nicht verpackt
sparer messungen so und jetzt kommt was
rein formale wenn ein system diese
eigenschaft hat folgt daraus aus
mathematischen gründen das in solchen
systemen verschränkung zusammenhänge
auftreten was da das kann man manchmal
jetzt sind wir irgendwie von diesem
nachweis ähnlichen geisterhaft endspurt
ganz tief eingetaucht in physik und
mathematik ich möchte noch mal ein
bisschen zurück als es gibt ja viele
kritiker an ihrem ansatz und sie müssen
in dem leben also klar noch das
irgendwie die skeptiker sind die
gesellschaft für wissenschaftliche
untersuchung der parawissenschaften aber
auch irgendwie wir haben mit mit einem
eth physiker noch gesprochen mediator
einer der sagt dann auch dass die uhr an
der wand mit mir oder mit dem gehirn
verschränkt ist ist wohl noch viel
unwahrscheinlicher ist herr von lukaku
von einer sekunde auf die nächste vom
erdboden verschwindet das heißt es gibt
schon berechtigte kritik an dem ansatz
sie müssen sich rechtfertigen aber ihr
ansatz ist sozusagen nicht auf externer
mächte und geistert sie haben zugelassen
dass irgendwie intel so zu klären das
ist eine empirische frage also natürlich
würde ich von anfang an auch sagen ja
das ist extrem unwahrscheinlich dass ich
jetzt meinetwegen hier mit dieser wasser
kann er da verschränkt bin warum sollte
das sein so und das ist eine empirische
frage also ich hab ja vorhin den begriff
des embodiment verwenden können probleme
heißt eingebettet sein in die umgebung
und der mensch ist immer eingebettet und
seine umgebung und die setzt sich
zusammen aus allem möglichen
physikalisch also meine wohnung ist in
vieler vielfältiger weise mit mir
physical verbunden temperatur
luftfeuchtigkeit alles mögliche größe
des raums aber auch ob mir die wohnung
gefällt vielleicht auch mit der
geschichte der wohnung ob ich in einem
haus wohnen wo ich mich wohlfühle oder
ob ich im haus hat wo vorher jemand
umgebracht wurde da fühle ich mich
vielleicht nicht so wohl also embodiment
heißt dass es viele viele kausale
unterschiedliche zusammenhänge gibt die
mich sozusagen in meiner umgebung
einpassen und das nennt man ein paar
demand ist ein begriff aus der
kognitionspsychologie unter robotnik
übrigens ja so jetzt passende auf wenn
man annimmt dass der mensch auf so
vielfältige kausale art und weise mit
seiner umgebung verbunden ist und wenn
bei der beschreibung nicht vertauscht
aber paare ob serbien auftreten dann
wird man erwarten dass in dem system
verschränkung auftritt jetzt muss man
das überprüfen das weiß man nicht von
ball und deswegen habe ich experimente
angestellt ich habe das experiment
herausgefunden dass man diese
verschränkung nachweisen kann
genauso wie über diese experimente
können wir vielleicht noch sprechen
möchte erst noch mal einen schritt
weiter gehen und andere phänomene gern
gucke nämlich geister also viele
menschen berichten ja davon dass sie
einen geist gesehen haben gespürt haben
von einem verstorbenen und es gibt den
schönen film arme seelen die arbeiten
solche geschichten erden gehören uns mal
eine davon an der habsucht die komplette
ausbildung der stiefvater und den osten
und 2003 ließen
versagt
[Musik]
durch die räume zu dir und du bist
arthrose und hatten die damen ja so
keine angst haben sie sogar hatten immer
diesen eindruck sie sehe da schon eher
geist hat diese verein geist gesehen
oder haben sie halluziniert ist schwer
zu entscheiden im einzelfall aber
möglich weiß er hat sie tatsächlich was
gesehen also bei den spuk vertreten auch
solche erscheinungen auf da weiß man
meistens nicht ob es eine halluzination
ist oder nicht aber halluzinationen
kommen jeden tag vor vor allem dann wenn
man natürlich angespannt ist oder angst
hat oder wenn unklare verhältnisse sind
wenn ich nachts durch die landschaft
laufe dann gibt es also diesen gestalt
wahrnehmungs effekt dass ich überall
gestalten sie wenn ich dir jemand anders
zeigt sie dass er auch wir haben hier
noch ein bier mitgebracht jedermann
schwarze flecken erfahren genau grund
sieht aber wenn man das stimmte weise
anguckt sieht man etwas nämlich ein huhn
und ei nem der albertina der genannten
kopf auf den boden erreicht ist und wenn
man dann mal gesehen hat sind da geht es
nicht mehr weg gar nicht mehr weg ja was
erstaunt waren das nicht mal gestalt
wahrnehmung und es ist natürlich sicher
so dass also wir haben eine riesige
sammlung von fotos die uns zugeschickt
worden sind das kann man experiment
herausfinden ob es gestalt wahrnehmung
ist oder nicht indem man einfach mehrere
leute befragt und gefragt wo sie was
sehen und dann kann man es miteinander
vergleichen und dann stellt man fest
dass gestalt waren aber sie würden sagen
diese frau die wir im einspieler gesehen
haben da ist nicht sicher ob die
wirklich etwas gesehen hat also einen
geist war oder ob sie die bloße gestaut
wahrnehmung hatte war es ein bisschen
nun kann man also einen moment das sind
zwei verschiedene dinge ob sein geist
war wissen natürlich überhaupt nicht was
ist ein geist ein geist ist ein
konstrukt was eigentlich nichts erklärt
sondern das ist nur ein bild so wie
früher die leute gesagt haben wenn es
blitzt das ist doch noch gott oder der
oder man geht davon aus wenn da wirklich
der verstorbene nochmal kommt da ist das
zusätzliche etwas im raum und sonst sehe
ich einfach so aus wäre es kommt ein
wichtiger punkt hinzu ich habe ja vorhin
von diesem moment gesprochen
demand gehört dazu die geschichte und
wenn es dann ort gibt wo es na ja
unheimlich zugeht dann ist diese
geschichte natürlich präsent und das
heißt wenn wir schon feststellen dass
der mensch auf eine subtile art und
weise mit seiner umgebung verbunden ist
also verschränkt ist ist nicht
auszuschließen dass dann in der umgebung
auch optische erscheinung auftreten die
sonst nicht auftreten würden das kann
man aber im einzelfall nicht entscheiden
deswegen ist es ziemlich hoffnungslos
aber ich halte es nicht für
ausgeschlossen
jetzt muss ich aber da was ganz
wichtiges dazu sagen
man kann diese verschränkung
zusammenhänge eigentlich nie in reinster
form sehen das kann man kriegt ja
experimentellen mit großem aufwand hin
aber beim sport oder bei solchen
erlebnissen
da kann man nie ausschließen ob das
jetzt vielleicht eine halluzination ist
ob es einbildung ist oder gestalt
wahrnehmung oder ein ganz großer effekt
dass da eben trust hat jemand vorbei
gelaufen ist so und das nenne ich
makroskopische unentschuldbar kite das
eigentlich sind die normalen fälle von
paranormalen erfahrungen wie wir sie
hier gehört haben immer so dass man sie
nie rest endlich entscheiden kann
sondern das ist immer offen es kann
alles
möglich seien jetzt kommt etwas ganz
wichtiges die natur ist so gebaut dass
diese verschränkung zusammenhänge nur
auftreten in solchen situationen wo es
ganz viele kaufe alle ursachen gibt wo
embodiment ist wo viele dinge
zusammenkommen und dann entsteht
verschränkung also verschränkung fällt
nicht vom himmel
verschränkung ist ein eine eigenschaft
eines hochdynamischen systems in denen
ganz viele tausend alle zusammenhänge
existieren und ich erkläre das immer mit
folgendem bild die kausalen
zusammenhänge sind wie ein schwamm ein
trockener schwamm
da der spröde und hart aber der ist so
stabil und weiß ganz genau wie der
gebaut ist eine struktur die
verschränkung ist wie wasser
die ist flüchtig die ist liquide die
kann ich nicht in griff kriegen
und wenn ich sie ergreifen will dann ist
sie weg dann fließt sie davon
wenn ich aber schwamm und wasser
zusammentun dann kann sie ordentlich
putzen und die natur macht es ganz
genauso
die nimmt diese psychologischen
verschränkung zusammenhänge die auch
physikalisch sich auswirken kann und der
kausale schwamm saugt das gewissermaßen
aus und dann passieren solche erlebnisse
von lucadou sie könnten wir hier
irgendwas und großen bären aufbinden und
ich muss nicht rausfinden ja es ist
irgendwie so schwierig weil wenn man
nicht an diese dinge glaubt dann sucht
man immer nach anderen erklärungen sie
passen nicht ins weltbild und mich würde
interessieren
so viele menschen haben diese sehnsucht
nach etwas über sind ja gut
manchmal ist steckt ein wunsch dahinter
muss man angst ja warum haben die
menschen also die antwort ist ganz
simpel weil sie solche sachen erleben
wenn menschen niemals solche situationen
erleben würden würden sie gar nicht auf
die idee kommen dann würde alles ganz
rational und ordentlich zu gehen und
dann gibt's die frage gar nicht
also das heißt die tatsache dass
menschen solche erlebnisse schon immer
gehabt haben
und nur weil die aufklärung daher kam
und gesagt hat es gibt alles nicht alles
wir haben alles im griff
wurden diese erlebnisse die in anderen
kulturen sehr wohl ihre stellung
haben und die auch ernst genommen werden
sie wurden einfach unter den teppich
gekehrt und was wir jetzt machen ist wir
sagen okay wir haben ein gutes modell
wir sagen das sind sowohl kausale als
auch verschränkung zusammenhänge und das
kann man experimentell überprüfen und
das habe ich gemacht und ich würde jetzt
hier nicht so keck sein in hier solche
geschichten oder modelle erzählen wenn
es nicht so wäre und das ist wirklich
erstaunlich ich habe vor 30 jahren
begonnen solche experimente zu machen
und jetzt gibt es mittlerweile ungefähr
12 13 universitäten sind diese
experimente nach gemacht worden und die
zeigen genau den zusammenhang der nicht
arbeitet dann kriegen sie also demnächst
dennoch kann ein da kriegt man nicht für
parapsychologie das kann man vergessen
warum nicht
doch eine echte wissenschaft habe das
funktioniert anders wir sind die die das
mainstream da haben sie tausende von
wissenschaftlern die auf einem gebiet
arbeiten und erst wenn zb das bälde
experiment oder irgendein anderes
tausend mal durchgeführt worden ist und
jedes mal kommt das gleiche raus dann
sagen die ok darauf können wir uns
verlassen dann kommt in die schulbücher
und dann kriegen sie vielleicht
nobelpreis das ist meine haare nicht für
solche fragen die noch die sind
vielleicht in 50 jahren einigermaßen
gesichert aber jetzt das bin ich ja
schon sparen weil man so wenn man in die
wissenschaftsgeschichte zurück gab es ja
immer diese welt bilder die sich
ablösten richten ich bin der überzeugung
dass die erde im mittelpunkt des ganzen
ist dann hin zu einem weltweit über
irgend einem rand sind und das waren so
lange prozesse und der
wissenschaftshistoriker thomas kuhn
diarra von revolutionen vor lang
wissenschaftlichen theorien und sagt es
gibt solche paradigmen in denen man
denkt und wenn da irgendwelche störungen
auftreten dann sind das anomalien die
reaktionen die erstmal weg geschoben
werden
das heißt sie plädieren eigentlich für
einen paradigmenwechsel
tja also da muss man auch ein bisschen
wieder die luft rauslassen
paradigmenwechsel kann man immer erst
hinterher feststellen wenn es sozusagen
längst in den schulbüchern steht also
natürlich war die entdeckung der
quantenphysiker paradigmenwechsel oder
die relativitätstheorie aber er
nach 100 jahren stellt man fest dass das
wirklich ein paradigmenwechsel seien nun
ist es so mode geworden bei jeder neuen
geschichte die da diskutiert wird in der
wissenschaft zugleich von den
paradigmenwechsel zu sprechen also
erstens stimmt es so auch nicht und
zweitens ist es eigentlich eher so wenn
man das modell was ich jetzt hier
skizziert habe mal nimmt dann stellt man
fest dass das eigentlich nichts neues zu
dem hinzufügt was wir nicht schon wissen
es nimmt sogar ein bisschen weg denn
bisher hat man immer geglaubt in der
parapsychologie braucht man eine extra
kraft und geisterhafte energie oder
sonst weisen oder das jenseits oder was
auch immer
erleben sie außerhalb aber sie schließen
das nicht ganz an das kann man in der
wissenschaft nie also es kann immer
richtig sein aber es schwer zu
falsifizieren ja also zusagen sind geist
kann ich immer behaupten dann hat mal
ganz lange in der parapsychologie die
strategie verfolgt und hat nach einer
extra kraft gesucht experimentelle hat
sie aber nicht gefunden ja und jetzt die
dritte stadium in dem wir jetzt uns
befinden sagen wir müssen von der physik
ein bisschen was weglassen und dann
kriegen wir gutes modell nämlich diese
verallgemeinerte quantentheorie ist
nicht zusatz zur physik sondern sie
lässt was wächst lässt nämlich die ganze
physik weg und übernimmt nur diese nicht
vertauscht barkeit von ups erwarten das
ist weniger als physik und damit kann es
schaffen das ist also interessant wir
müssen keine zusatz annahmen machen wir
müssen nur ernst nehmen was wir jetzt
schon wissen dass es gut war dass ich
meine sparsamkeit ist ja wie terium von
theorien und sollen nicht irgendwelche
dinge annehmen die man nicht unbedingt
braucht und man extra klären und noch
keine zwei semester jetzt wir haben
eigentlich schon lange geredet mich
würde mal interessieren dass fast alle
kennen dieses phänomen das man auch
jemanden denkt ja und dann klingelt das
telefon und ruft dann ist das für sie
bloßer zufall den wir so selektiv
wahrnehmen dass wir sagen
jetzt fangen gedankenübertragung der
stadt telepathie oder ist das gibt's
dass das wurde sogar experimente
ausprobieren
rupert sheldrake englisch biologie den
ich auch gut kennen der viele bühne
geschrieben hat über so eine art extra
kraft dessen der fische resonanz mit dem
streite ich mich immer gerne und er hat
gesagt er hat es nur das suchte und
herausgefunden dass tatsächlich die
leute häufiger genau dann ans telefon
gehen wenn sie gerade jemand anruft ist
ein gästehaus sei ja ein bisschen besser
als das war einfach das gab es viele
experiment jahres gab viele experimente
und die effekte sind nicht sehr stark
ich verstehe und es ist ja auch nicht so
einfach her wälzen schwacher effekt ist
und sie sind auch schlecht
reproduzierbar
aber der entscheidende punkt war bei der
ganzen diskussion ist es ist ein zeichen
für verschränkungen weil wenn ich meine
freundin anruf und er geht es gerade
schlecht dann kann ich sagen naja ich
bin halt mit der verschränkt also weil
weil ich sie mag ja das zur bindung
werden schönes beispiel für
verschränkung mutter kind beziehungen
verliebtheit und das und dann kann es
schon passieren dass so was häufiger
passiert als ein zufall entspricht aber
das dumme ist ich kann es nicht
verwenden also wenn ich dann denke ich
brauche ich gar nicht um ein kind zu
kümmern uns kritisch wird dann wird
schon die tell partie funktionieren dann
funktioniert gerade nicht warum weil die
verschränkung nicht diese eigenschaft
hat und das nennen wir nt achse um nt
aktion heißt das immer dann wenn ich
versuche diese verschränkung zu benutzen
praktisch zu benutzen das versuchen ja
viele dann mache ich sie gerade kaputt
weil ich das system zu ändern dass es
nicht mehr funktionieren kann ja viele
erste esoterischen cd daher sage ich
sachen anbieten und so rund und man
dagegen sind sie natürlich ja also ich
meine jetzt laufen sie ihr geld ich den
leuten sparen können wenn sie vorher
anrufen würden um zu fragen ob sie da in
also irgendwie tausend euro investieren
sollen da kann ich den leuten sagen dass
das fatale ich jetzt mal eine geschichte
die wirklich passiert ist
er hat mich ein herangerufen der sehr
reich war
und der war immobilienmakler und der
kann den helferinnen und der hat gesagt
da rief mich an war ganz aufgeregt und
hat gesagt also ich mache hier keine
späße aber ich habe diese frau getestet
die canvas die er hat mir sachen aus
meinem leben gesagt das kann sie gar
nicht wissen
und die sagt mir jetzt voraus dass es
eine flutkatastrophe geben wird und alle
meine grundstücke ist gehen den bach
runter und die müsste ich jetzt sofort
verkaufen aber dann verkaufe ich die
unter unserem wert weil gegenwärtig die
konjunktur nicht passt die würde ich
gerne behalten was sagen sie mir und er
hat genau das datum genannt august sowie
und dann habe ich eine weile mit ihm
geredet ich habe natürlich meine modell
im hinterkopf und nach einer kurzen zeit
ich gebe ihnen die lösung gleich ganz
pro jahr habe ich ihm gesagt behalten
sie ihre grundstücke ich bin zwar kein
meteorologe fragen sie damals noch nach
ob es eine sturmflut gehen kann aber da
wird nichts passieren
und der termin kam immer näher und ich
habe natürlich die wette gewonnen ich
habe noch nie eine wette verloren in
bezug auf solche voraussagen warum weil
ich weiß wie es funktioniert
es gibt zwar es gab zwar eine
verschränkung zwischen dieser helsinn
und diesem herrn der hat die hat
tatsächlich sachen die emotional für ihn
wichtig war ihm von der nase abgelesen
telepathie naja also sie hat es eben
herausgefunden
das ist ein kompliziertes und es hat uns
sehr beeindruckt aber was sie nicht kann
sie kann ihre spontanen intuitiven
eindrücke nicht präzise wie ein kausalen
effekt betrachten sondern das ist
allenfalls eine muster übereinstimmung
und mehr mal raus findet dass diese
muster übereinstimmung sich gar nicht
auf diese zukunft bezieht sondern auf
die vergangenheit dann kann man sagen
okay dann mal was anderes und so kann
man vorgehen ja also das funktioniert
was was müsste passieren damit sie
anfangen an geister zu glauben für euch
also schauen sie selbst und mir eins
einer hier erscheinen würde
da würde ich erst mal an nehmen das
signal uzi nationen habe und dann würde
ich fragen ob sie es auch gesehen habe
haben und dann würde ich es halt
analysieren und wenn dann auch noch auf
der kamera drauf ist dann würde ich
sagen okay jetzt haben wir ein echtes
problem
aber es gab es bisher noch nie und was
kommt nach dem tod
das wissen wir alle nicht wenn wir es
wüssten würde ich ihn sofort verraten
aber ich sag gleich dazu ich habe
überhaupt nichts dagegen wenn leute
glauben dass es ein jenseits gibt wo sie
weiter existieren oder wo die seele
weiter existiert ich meine ich kann
nicht das gegenteil beweisen und solange
das nicht sagen kann darf doch jeder
glauben was er will und es ist überhaupt
nicht unanständig an ein leben nach dem
tod zu glauben ich kann es ja auch nicht
wissen ich würde nur sagen na sollen mit
allem rechnen
und was ist zum schluss was ist für sie
das größte rätsel auf dieser welt das
größte rätsel ist in der tat für mich
warum es tatsächlich warum die welt so
aufgebaut ist dass es auch solche
makroskopischen verschränkungen gibt es
würde mir gar nicht erwarten aber die
welt ist wohl so aufgebaut und warum das
gerade so ist richtiges geheimnis also
auch warum die physik funktioniert das
finde ich ganz erstaunlich wie also wir
leben hier das was mich am meisten
fasziniert hat war der beginn der
quantenphysik das war nämlich als max
planck in seiner studierstube das
spanische strahlungs gesetz abgeleitet
und aufgeschrieben hat und zu seinem
ganzen missbehagen musste er feststellen
dass die energie gewandelt ist es wollte
gar nicht glauben da waren kleines
richtig kommen genau und er hatte also
noch ganz klassisch gedacht so und
dieses gesetz kennen wir und es lernt
jeder physikstudent und vor ein paar
jahren ist ein satellit ins weltall
geflogen und hat festgestellt dass
dieses gesetz auch noch in zehn
milliarden lichtjahren entfernung
genauso gilt wie das was er an
am schreibtisch niedergeschrieben hat
das ist fantastisch das ist so
unglaublich dass der mensch mit seinem
gehirn dinge erkennen kann die soweit
wechseln
das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
das finde ich es ist erstaunlich was
glauben sie daran dass eine ähnliche
theorie wäre mit der verschränkung
irgendwann marktkonsens ist das glaub
ich eigentlich schon und zwar das ja
einfach deswegen weil das eigentlich so
naheliegend ist und weil wir in der
psychologie sozusagen ständig mit nicht
vertauscht barren ob serbien zu tun
haben das ist was selbstverständlich nur
hat niemand für den ganzen psychologen
sich so genügend mit physik ausgedacht
gekannt und hat gesehen dass das
konsequenzen hat das ist so ist
bezweifelt jan ehmann aber dass dahinter
das als resultat die verschränkung
auskommt das hat man nicht erwartet man
jetzt einfach nicht betrachtet man hat
nicht hingeguckt
es ist aber eigentlich
selbstverständlich ist ganz simpel ist
jemanden der psychologe und physiker ja
also das heißt man muss sie ein bisschen
dran gewöhnen aber an die quantenphysik
an als sie ja erst mal 100 jahre
geworden müssen ich muss mich ja auch
noch ein bisschen daran gewöhnen aber es
war sehr hellen vielen herzlichen dank
für dieses gespräch haben lucadou ja
nächste woche spricht meine kollegin
barbara bleisch mit dem amerikanischen
politik wissenschaftler mark lilla über
die zukunft der usa und über die essenz
des reaktionären denkens das gerade
wieder salonfähig wird
und jetzt gleich folgt das abstimmungs
studio bleiben sie also dran
[Musik]